Bayern unter Zugzwang - beim Fingerhakeln.
Einer der besten: Josef Utzschneider.
Das Faszinierende ist, dass man alle
Sinne braucht eigentlich!
Beim Fingerhakeln geht es darum, den
anderen über den Tisch zu ziehen.
Man braucht Schnellkraft, man braucht [eine]
Kondition, man braucht einen Finger.
Ohne diesen trainierten Finger… ohne den
funktioniert gar nichts.
Es ist eine bayerische Tradition. Früher ein
Kräftemessen im Wirtshaus.
Heute ein ernsthafter Sport mit richtigen
Meisterschaften.
Das Interessante ist, dass, wenn einer da ist,
der [wo] alle Kraft der Welt hat,
aber halt keinen guten Finger, keine
Schnellkraft, der macht keinen Stich.
Das macht die Sportart eigentlich aus, dass
man alles braucht
und auf die Zehntelsekunde da sein muss.
Da sein muss auch das, was sonst zu Bayern
gehört: Blasmusik und Bier.
In Reichertshofen bei Nürnberg werden die
61. Bayerischen Meisterschaften
im Fingerhakeln ausgetragen.
Rund 120 Teilnehmer treten an - und müssen
sich einem klaren Regelwerk fügen -
unter den Augen von Schiedsrichter Helmut
Weiß.
Sie dürfen halt einhakeln mit dem
Mittelfinger, Ringfinger,
ist eigentlich egal welchem Finger, man darf
alle nehmen bis auf den Daumen
und kleinen Finger.
Dann darf man einen Fuß, den Zugfuß, am
Tisch einspreizen, die andere Hand auch,
dann kommt‘s Kommando:
'Beide Hakler, fertig, zieht!' Bei 'Zieht!' Geht's
los,
und ab 'Zieht!' darf jeder den zweiten Fuß zur
Hilfe nehmen.
Da ist praktisch die Anfangslinie … Mittel …
Ring.
Die Außenlinie muss der gegnerische Finger
überqueren, dann ist‘s aus.
Die Meisterschaften finden immer im
Wirtshaus oder Festzelt statt.
Dementsprechend ist auch die Stimmung.
Erste Vorbereitung:
körperliche Grundlagen schaffen.
Josef Utzschneider tritt in der Königsdisziplin
an, dem Schwergewicht.
Mit leerem Magen funktioniert gar nichts!
Auch noch nicht mal das Fingerhakeln.
Im 16. Jahrhundert wurde das Fingerhakeln
erstmals erwähnt.
Damals ging es darum, Streit zu schlichten
oder Frauen zu imponieren.
Auch der Vorsitzende des
Fingerhakler-Verbandes,
Anton Bader, hakelt mit.
Es ist a [ein] Brauchtum in meinen Augen.
Und dann die Kameradschaft drumherum.
Du hockst dich hinauf, du kämpfst miteinand’
[miteinander] bis aufs Letzte
und danach umarmst’ [du] dich wieder und
trinkst miteinand’ [miteinander]
a [eine] Maß Bier oder was. Und das ist das
Allerschönste.
Mit Magnesia werden die Finger kurz vor dem
Kampf eingerieben,
damit sie trocken bleiben und der Haklerring
nicht so leicht abrutscht.
Josef Utzschneider hat sich dafür eine
richtige Hornhaut antrainiert.
Es geht jetzt allein’ ums, um dass man den
Finger halt auf Betriebstemperatur bringt und
… und, dass das halt alles dann, wenn es los
geht, gescheit hebt alles.
Aber beim Hakeln kommt es nicht nur auf den
Finger und die Muskeln an.
Kopf ist … mit entscheidend. Wenn … wenn‘s
wirklich … wenn‘s zwoa [zwei] ganz
Gleichwertige sind, und der andere ist vom
Kopf her net [nicht] so auf‘m Damm,
dann ist das entscheidend.
Josef Utzschneider ist seit 12 Jahren
ungeschlagener bayerischer,
deutscher und alpenländischer Meister.
Auch hier macht er mit seinen Gegnern
kurzen Prozess.
Das ist a [auch] sexy irgendwie, finde ich, ne?
Weil …wenn die Männer da so sitzen und
ziehen mit ihrer Manneskraft,
also das ist schon schön zum Anschauen.
Das macht Riesenspaß. Ist halt brutal.
Ich würde es niemals selbst machen, aber [es]
ist auf jeden Fall immer wieder ein Spaß,
da zuzuschauen.
Auch im Finale zieht Josef Utzschneider
seinen Gegner über den Tisch.
Er ist neuer und alter bayerischer Meister.
Sein Preisgeld: Ruhm, Ehre und die
Kameradschaft unter den Haklern.
Jetzt … jetzt gehen wir zum gemütlichen Teil
über! Prost!
Das Fingerhakeln - ein bayerisches
Brauchtum, das einfach unschlagbar ist.